are we ready to get strong and toned
today's class is a low impact workout
focusing on building your strength and
muscular endurance so this workout
session is in partnership with circle
dna which is currently the world's most
comprehensive dna test i believe a lot
of you have seen my previous videos
where i shed my dna test results and
also explain how i've adapted my diet
and training methods to suit my body
type so be sure to check it out on my
youtube channel this test is really
simple and convenient upon purchase
you'll be sent the circle dna kit where
you'll be able to do the swap test at
home and send it back to them so once
your dna has been analyzed your results
will be delivered through their mobile
app which you can access anytime so this
one test can provide you with over 500
reports
based on my sports profile which is high
endurance medium power and low strength
i've started focusing more on improving
my strength but because i'm more
dominant towards endurance i want to use
that to my advantage by taking shorter
rest times in between sets so today's
workout is based on supersets where we
will be lifting light weights and
alternating it with bodyweight strength
exercises this workout will help you to
build a strong and toned body and to
also improve on your endurance ability
for those of you who are interested to
discover your own sports profile whether
you're more dominant to its strength
power or endurance then do check out
circle dna the link will be in my
description box below use the coupon
code joanna at checkout to get one kit
for 35 of 2-3 kids for 40 off and four
or more kids for 50 off so this is
applicable to any circle dna kit you
purchase and this offer is only limited
to the first 100 kids sold so be sure to
share this information with your family
and friends all you need is one test for
a lifetime because your genetics will
not change so this is an investment for
your health journey and with all the
information you have you will be able to
better plan your training as well as
diet and progress quicker in your
fitness goals so
let's get started
[Music]
there will be a total of eight supersets
and each superset will have two
exercises focusing on the same muscle
group so let's start with a quick
warm-up let's just start by tapping your
toes forward
okay just loosening up the joints
and now let's combine that with your
arms
for a chest
opener
good so really stretching your chest
feel the squeeze on
your back as well
this is just to get the blood flowing
and to increase our heart rate
keep tapping
feel more
and now just shake it out
give me feel
shoulder rolls
forward
big shoulder rolls forward and i want
you to continue marching okay so don't
stop moving
continue marching
and now back
good job
do more
and just shake it out
all right now step right at the edge of
your mat
keep a slight bend in your knees what i
want to do is slowly inch forward
feel the stretch on your hamstrings
get into a high plank position
and now slowly
inch back
okay and stand tall stretch up again
down
feel the stretch on the hamstrings
into a high plank
and slowly
push yourself back up and stretch look
up now to challenge yourself keep your
legs straight feel a deeper stretch in
your hamstrings
get into a high plank give me one
push-up down
push yourself up
and slowly
inch
back
up
one more okay
back down straight legs
yup can you feel that stretch
it's so tight
high plank one push-up
if you want to get onto your knees you
can as well
slowly push yourself back up and up okay
now just a few lunges okay lunge forward
stretch up
push yourself back
forward push yourself back
and tap
good job
remember to always keep your back flat
chest
open
and stand in a neutral position
forward
back
one more
and come back to the center and just
shake it out okay so for the first
workout
grab your dumbbells okay choose between
four to six kilos each so the first
workout will be a front squat so stand
shoulder width apart with your toes
pointed forward place the dumbbells in
front of you and just push your butt
back
and up good job
slow pace and push it up so the tempo
will be three one two three
and up
one two three and push yourself up so
let me show you from the side push your
butt back chest tall
and push it up good job
so it's going to be a 45 seconds workout
with a 15 seconds rest in between
[Music]
and push
so all the exercises will be low impact
okay
no jumping throughout the entire workout
really focusing on your legs and your
glutes good
drop the dumbbells down
now we want to alternate with squat
pulses okay so three squat pulses and
come back up it's going to be without
any weight just your body weight one two
three
up
one two three
ah good job
keep going small pulses
feel it right in the glutes
up
push it up
good job feel the burn on your thighs
remember that your knees should not go
over your toes so each superset will be
a combination of dumbbells with body
weight okay
push up
i'm starting to feel the burn
good job
push up one more
up grab your dumbbells
back into
front squat okay place the dumbbells
directly in front of you
toes pointing forward
in five seconds three counts down one
count up ready
one two three
push remember as you push up use the
strength and power from your heels
down slow
push so pushing
all the weight away from the ground good
job
[Music]
and breathe out as you push
up good
let's go
you are strong
this is all about building strength in
your body
so we're working on
compound movements
focusing on big muscle groups
push
that's one more slow do not rush through
the workout
last one and
drop the weights
all right
let's go for
squat pulses okay now give me five
pulses
and stand back up
forward ready push your butt back
one two three four five
squeeze
one two three stay low
up
push your back
good job do the burn that's what i want
one two three four five
up
one two
three four five and all the way up let's
go
halfway there
[Music]
breathe out same thing
every time you exert your strength
that's when you breathe out
two three four five
let's go two more okay one two three
four five
one more
two three four
five
okay
very well done take a short 40 seconds
break
that is the end of the first superset
okay now we want to move in to the
second superset still working on your
legs and your glutes
it's going to be lunges
so
grab the dumbbells alright
the first workout is going to be reverse
lunges so place both dumbbells up
step right in front of your mat and all
i want to do is step back
remember keep your legs in a 90 degree
position
and push up using the front leg
alternating
between legs
step forward
and back
always remember to keep a slight bend in
your knees
up if you can
try to go low
and get your knees to tap the floor okay
push good job
remember that the strength should be
coming from the front
heels
good
keep going
push push
nice
brace your car
find your balance
step forward
and try to stay
low
and up
good job
drop the weight
same thing just like the first workout
we want to go for lunge pulses so start
right at the front of your mat let's go
for three pulses
two three
change
again keeping your knees soft throughout
all right
so stay low
and you will constantly feel the tension
in your thighs and your butt that's what
we want that constant tension
up
change
two three
up
yep
your thighs are on fire i know that i
can feel it in my thighs as well
let's keep going
two three
up step low
two three
up
body weight strength training
it's still effective
up good job okay now let's repeat the
entire superset once more so grab your
weight okay if you find that the
dumbbells here it's so uncomfortable
what you can do is place the dumbbells
next to you
same thing reverse lunges step back
and forward
so choose your options okay
place the dumbbells either just by your
shoulders
or
just hold them next to you
step forward
up
and because our legs
are bigger muscle groups what you can do
is to lift heavier dumbbells if you want
to progress and challenge yourself you
can lift heavier
push
tap
push
good job look forward
raise your car
chest up
do not
hunch
or lean
forward okay
and up
drop the dumbbells oh my gosh
squat pulses okay this time let's
challenge ourselves and go for five
pulses let's start right
in the middle of your mat ready
one two three keep it small keep it low
change
good job two
three four five whoo
right
underneath your butt that's what we want
two
three four five change
if five puzzles is too much for you you
can go with three
okay but what i want to feel
is that slight challenge in every
workout that's how we progress and
that's how we push ourselves further and
see results
two
three four five one more on the left
side
two three
four five
okay
shake it out
i know how your legs are feeling well
good news
give your lower body a short break now
let's move on to our upper body so the
next superset will be focusing on your
chest muscles okay so grab the weights
and lie
down onto the floor
all right we want to start with chest
press
so place your heels close to your butt
lift the dumbbell straight up
making sure that both dumbbells are
directly in line with your chest slowly
lower the dumbbells down
and push it straight up okay
so relax your lower body
i want you to just focus on your upper
body
gently
tap the elbows
onto the floor and push it straight up
so you should feel the work on your
chest if you're feeling it in your
shoulders then the dumbbells
might be too high
making sure that the dumbbells are in
line
with
your chest push it up
and remember to always keep a slight
bend in your elbows
up good job
squeeze the chest muscles
let's have
firm
breaths
let's go push it up and now come back up
drop the weights
let's get into push-up okay so choose
your option either on your knees or on
your toes so let's start by doing
push-ups on our knees remember keeping
your back in a straight line lower your
body down
push it up
lower your body down
and up so two counts one two
and up in one count
control movement
push good job so strength training is
all about slow and controlled movement
focusing on
that particular muscle you're working on
down
up
good very good
push
and push it away
so
making sure that your pumps are in line
with your chest as well push
good job
and good you know the drill so grab the
dumbbells now let's lie straight down
onto the floor
chest press
keeping your heels close to your butt
dumbbells in line with your chest
lower it down
and push
lower it down
and push there you go
and a lot of female we tend to
not
want to train our chest
but it is equally just as important okay
push
slow it down
push
remember to breathe out as you push the
dumbbells
up
same thing two counts down
and push okay
one two
push it straight up
up
up
and
drop it back
down okay
now let's challenge ourselves let's do
push-ups on our toes okay so get onto
your toes ready spread your fingers
down
up same thing two counts down
push it up if this is too difficult you
can get on to your knees okay so choose
your option
and as you get stronger challenge
yourself
up
back down
up
back down
and up
very good
control
up
whoo
10 more seconds
keep going
push
two more
push give me two more
oh my sweat is dripping let's go
oh my gosh
okay oh my gosh strength training
short rest working on your endurance as
well now let's get back up
still working on your upper body okay we
want to work on our shoulders really
small muscle group but equally just as
important okay so if you want to lift
lighter weights you can
alright so the first exercise is going
to be a shoulder press so
grab the dumbbells you can go for
lighter weights lift it up
all i want you to do is press the
dumbbells straight up
back down
and straight up okay so spread your feet
toes pointer forward keep a neutral
position
press the dumbbells straight up brace
your core
try not to use any momentum as you press
the dumbbells up
so lower the dumbbells just by your ears
press it up
back down
press
oh strong shoulders
sexy arms let's go
press few more
up
up
give me two more
press i'm feeling the burn
and drop okay now let's get down onto
the floor okay
still working on our shoulders
plank up down i know this is a love-hate
relationship but it's really good for
your shoulders and your upper body
strength so start in a plank position
push yourself up
lower yourself down
and alternate
back down
push yourself up
back down
and up
good job
remember minimal movements
should be coming from your hips okay so
really brace the core keep
your back flat and really use the
strength from your upper body to push
yourself
up back down
up
and push
good job 10 more seconds
push
and we want to get back up
into
shoulder
press
and
back down
okay now short break get back up
grab your dumbbells okay
if you feel that your shoulders are
burning you can choose the lighter
weight let's go up
absolutely on fire press up
raise your core
press up
remember don't let don't just let the
weights drop
control it as it's coming down
press it back up
control
up
control
and up
good job
raise your core
up
and
oh my gosh i am dying i can feel the
burn if you need to you can use a little
bit of momentum to help you but not too
much okay
give me two
more one more
press up
down
and
back
down okay
back down on to the ground four
plank
up down so let's start in a plank
position
keeping your elbows in line with your
shoulders
are we ready let's go push yourself up
back down
alternate
and back down
[Music]
control
push up
and control
good job there you go
remember to
pace your breathing okay do not just
hold your breath
keep breathing throughout the workout
i know i'm feeling it right in my
shoulders
that's the kind of burn we want
down up
back down
push up
back down
up
that's one more
and drop it down
okay
all right
guess what
we are halfway through our supersets if
you feel that you need to take a short
break then
give yourself a short break grab some
water and keep yourself hydrated okay
and i'll see you for the next four more
supersets
[Music]
we are half way through so four more
supersets to go the next superset will
focus on our back muscles okay so the
first workout will be renegade row this
workout can be slightly tougher but it
is really effective to work on your back
and also your core so place the
dumbbells right in front of you get into
a plank position and all i want you to
do is pull the dumbbells close to your
belly
with your elbows pointing back okay if
you feel that gosh my wrists are hurting
what you can do is place one palm down
pull it up
place your palm down and
alternating between the dumbbells if you
find that
you're struggling with your balance what
you can do is get onto
your knees okay so choose your option
otherwise stay with me both dumbbells in
your hands
and pull it with your elbows pointing
back feel the squeeze on your mid
back pull
and squeeze remember to point your
elbows back okay good now just place the
dumbbell next to you
lie flat down
onto the floor what we want to do is
back extension okay so look down onto
the floor all i want you to do is
lift your upper body up so relax your
lower body lift it up
feel the squeeze on your back
and now let's work on our legs as well
so as you lift it up
squeeze your legs release
and back down
up
squeeze
and back down
so gaze onto the floor
working on our back muscles
up
squeeze
down good job
just focusing on your upper body okay
and down
up
squeeze
and down okay
push yourself back up
grab your dumbbells now that you know
the movement choose your option okay
either on your knees
one pump on the floor or grab both
dumbbells with both hands
spread your feet wider pull and squeeze
okay
and squeeze
good job there you go
raise your core
find your balance remember
do not rotate your hips okay if you're
doing this
this is wrong okay no hip rotation
the strength
should be coming
from
your upper body who
good job
squeeze
squeeze very good
strong back
strong shoulders as well squeeze
that's one more
and
good
now place the dumbbells next to you
back extension so
lie straight down
okay arms forward remember all i want
you to do is raise up
squeeze your legs only for one count
and lower yourself back down
up
squeeze
and down
breathe out
as you squeeze your legs up
squeeze
try to reach as high as you can
and squeeze
good job
up
squeeze
and relax
few more
i know i'm feeling it right in my back
let's go
sexy back
release
and up
squeeze
and release
and
get back up okay
now that we've worked on our upper body
let's move back onto our lower body and
this time we want to target the glutes
okay so lie straight down onto the floor
all right the next workout is going to
be weighted glute bridge so all i want
to do is place the dumbbells just right
on your hips keep your
heels close to your butt
and what a way to do is raise your butt
up
squeeze it for two counts
lower it in a controlled manner
and
raise it up okay
so placing the dumbbells
on
your hips up squeeze two counts
lower
do not rest back up squeeze good job
there you go
all the tension all the work
should be
on your glutes
up squeeze
nice
remember we're not rushing through the
workout so don't do this okay
control
up
and back down
up
and back down good job
whoo feeling
i am feeling it
squeeze
back down and good okay just drop the
weights next to you still in this
position what we want to do is single
leg glute bridge pulses okay so place
your hands next to you keep your left
leg straight now get back up
three pulses
back down
one
two
three small pulses lower yourself down
one
two
three
back down
up
two
three okay
can you feel that
in your right
butt
slow
up
two three so even if you don't have any
weights at home
all these small modifications will
really help you
to work on your strength and to develop
a strong
lower body up point your toes
one
two
three
and back down okay
whoo
give your right side a break now
let's grab both dumbbells place it just
on your hips okay keeping your toes
pointed forward heels
firmly on the ground let's go up squeeze
back down don't worry we'll get back
onto working on the left side after this
up squeeze good job two counts
up
and squeeze
down one two
no resting
back down
up
squeeze it
there you go
imagine that there's a string pulling
you up holding you tight
and fighting against that resistance
squeeze
very good
squeeze last one more
and just drop the weights alright so now
let's work on our left
butt
keep your right leg straight
place both hands just next to you firmly
on the ground are we ready let's go
one
two
three small pulses back down
one
two
three
down
up
two
three good job if you're telling me that
you're feeling it more on your
hamstrings then
keep your heels closer to
your body okay
good job
up
two
three
oh feeling that burn
two three
right leg straight
up
two
three we are not resting
let's just keep pulsing
let's scout our butt up
two three
and drop back down
very well done oh my gosh it hurts okay
now push yourself back up
all right
still working on your lower body
this time we want to work on the outer
thighs okay and also on your outer
glutes as well so what i'm going to do
is just
relax your upper body place one dumbbell
on
the top leg and all i want to do is
relax your lower leg
lift it point and squeeze okay that's
all so gently tap
lift it up and squeeze
so you should feel the work
on your outer thigh
squeeze
gently
and squeeze so remember
don't just drop it control every
movement up
control
up
and control
good job up
gently
up do not rest okay just lower it back
down
and back up
changing position
working on your outer thighs and glutes
now
the previous superset was to work on the
entire glutes and also mainly focusing
on the lower butt okay now drop the
dumbbell
what i want to do is get back up okay
get into a standing position curtsy
lunges
so what i'm going to do is
place your left leg back
okay get low and just pulse
two
three
tap
one
two
three
tap okay
small pulses
remember it's a curtsy lunge so cross
your leg over not too far
as long as you feel it right
on the outer glutes
two three
tap
keep a slight bend in your knees
tap good job
lower yourself two
three
just working on the right side to begin
with
tap
give me two more okay
tap
yep feel that burn
very specific muscle tap okay good job
now
lie back down
switch side okay now we want to work on
the left side alright so
point your left leg straight out toes
pointed and same thing
raise slow it down
squeeze
and back down
up good job
up squeeze it okay remember you're
kicking straight up
in a straight line
squeeze
one two
up no resting
let's go
back down halfway there
squeeze it good
up
[Music]
oh my gosh
oh
my entire legs are on fire right now my
thighs my glutes from every angle let's
keep going
and back down okay drop the dumbbell
okay
let's get back up into curtsy lunge so
changing the other side right leg back
left leg forward remember three small
pulses and step in okay one
two three
tap
back down one two three
tap
remember to always keep a slight bend in
your knees people tend to forget this
okay because we want to have that
constant tension
throughout the entire workout two three
tap
don't cross too far okay
as long as you can find your balance and
you're feeling it in your outer glutes
that's what we want right here
two three
tap
give me two more okay
tap
one more
two three
tap
and come on one more
and
oh my gosh okay check it out relax your
legs we are done with our legs our upper
body and there's one more superset left
which is your core okay so for this next
superset all you need is only
one dumbbell okay so
grab the dumbbell
with both hands
lie straight down onto the floor and
what we want to do is weighted crunches
alright so keep both legs in a 90 degree
position
reach out
as you crunch up
bring the dumbbell across
and towards your ankle
if you find that this is too tough what
you can do is drop the weight and just
use your body weight okay so choose your
option
again nice and controlled movement
breathe out as you come up
good job
feeling it in your upper abs and also
your lower abs
and only lower your legs as low as you
can without overarching your lower back
up
back down
up
and down
keep going
one more and drop it down okay so just
drop the weights
come back up
still in a sitting position
and now we want to work on our lower abs
okay so it's going to be single leg knee
tucks
support your upper body let's go
straight legs one leg in
and alternating between the left
and
the right
single leg
knee tuck
okay
push it
drive your knee
close to your chest
and keep breathing right don't hold your
breath sometimes i tend to see that
someone they will just hold their breath
and do not breathe throughout the entire
exercise that does not help the workout
it will not make it any easier so
remember pace your breathing
and as i'm talking i'm breathing drop it
down all right
one final round and we are done
let's go
grab the dumbbell
with or without dumbbell
let's finish this strong okay legs up
extend
crunch
extend
crunch
good job
we are finishing this entire
40 minutes workout strong
stay with me
you are almost there
[Music]
breathe
crunch up
reach as far as you can
towards your ankle
extend both legs
up
extend
and up
that's 10 more
seconds strong
core
let's tone the midsection
and good job
just drop it down
push yourself back up okay
one final workout
45 seconds and you are done so support
your upper body remember to keep both
legs straight if you need to you can
tap and relax your heels on the floor
okay if not let's go challenge yourself
up
and
go for alternate
knee tucks
drive your knees
in towards your chest
feel the burn
we are almost there 20 seconds
oh this is a total body
strength
training workout
we've worked on our lower body
our upper body and we're finishing with
our core okay let's go
few more
two
three
and drop it down
oh my
gosh
okay
very very well done
can you believe it you are at the end of
your strength training workout you have
completed a total of eight super sets i
don't want you to rush and just dash off
right now
let's just spend two minutes to cool
down okay so just
spread your feet your thighs slightly
apart and just reach forward
get into a child's pose
and just relax
listen to your breath
and slowly pay attention to your breath
and we want to take this time
to bring our heart rate back down
okay
all right now slowly push yourself up
bring your knees together
and
let's do a few stretches for your legs
we've done a lot of lower body workout
step your left leg forward okay and just
drop your body weight forward remember
push your body weight forward
okay and now raise both arms up
and just look straight ahead
let's just hold this stretch for 10
seconds
and just breathe
okay
you've completed the entire workout so
this is your time to celebrate
and now just twist your body
and
look as far as you can
feel the stretch on your back
okay
good job
and now what i want to do is straighten
your front leg
to stretch out your hamstrings okay so
you should feel the stretch right here i
have tight hamstrings so only go as far
as you can okay
if you can't go deeper then feel free to
go deeper
all right
and remember
as you stretch breathe out
and go deeper okay that's how you
improve on your stretch
all right and now bend your front leg
and just lower your body weight down
and you should feel the stretch on your
glutes as well as your hip flexor so
this is a really good deep stretch for
your lower body
just hold it right here
if you want you can just reach forward
reach further forward and go for a
deeper stretch
and now push yourself back up
back into the starting position and
change the other side so right leg
forward
push your body weight
forward
arms up
stand tall chest open
and feel proud of yourself
take all the good energy in
we're going to start our day strong or
and our day really strong
okay now twist
look the opposite side reach as far as
you can
remember to keep your back flat okay
good job
and now straighten your front leg
feel the stretch on your hamstrings okay
only go as deep as you can
don't worry if you can't stretch as deep
it takes practice
stretching and flexibility takes
practice as well and the more you
practice it the better you will get at
it
okay and now fold the front leg
and same thing
drop
your body down
and reach forward feel the stretch on
your right glute and also hip flexor
if you want you can reach deeper
good job and now just slowly push
yourself back up now let's get into a
standing position okay to finish the
workout push yourself up
stand tall
all right
and now just give me few big
arm circles
just loosen everything out
you've done such a good job
back
big swings
ah
give me big size as well
very good
okay
and
thank you very much for joining me in
this 40 minute strength training workout
i hope that at the end of this workout
you're feeling much stronger and that
you will continue to do this workout
regularly okay and if you want more
workout videos do check it out on my
youtube channel don't forget to also hit
the subscribe button if you haven't yet
done it and like this video share this
video with your friends and also do
check out a lot more workout tips and
also recipe videos on my youtube channel
and i will see you in my next workout
all the best